développer cette citation Dieu m'a donné
la foi puis je ne sais quoi c'est la
lumière qui guide mes pas
quoi
en Dieu et après ben on a la lumière ça
c'est obligé
mais parfois la lumière elle marche pas
mais c'est pas la lumière du jour c'est
la lumière n'importe que vous soyez que
ça voudrait à une table vous êtes encore
avec Dieu vous êtes toujours avec lui au
grenier dans votre maison partout un
même au grenier partout et dans la cave
qui es-tu toi qui me tutoie si tu me
tutoies je te tue toi
ce n'est pas parce que tu n'as jamais vu
le lion chasser qu'il est végétarien
non c'est
pas besoin de rien envie de toi comme
jamais envie de personne c'est un truc
de c'est un peu chaud ça non
ça dépend comment on le comprend on
comprend si on le comprend au point de
vue physique ou au point de vue
spirituel
il y a aussi le point de vue spirituel
tu peux penser soit au cul soit à la
tête quoi
besoin de toi envie de rien la personne
oh c'était un couple ringard dans les
années
4,75-80 85 comment il s'appelait
les filles de mon pays là il aille ah
oui c'est court c'est une citation de
Enrico Macias
elles sont jolies les filles de mon pays
il faut développer
donc faut parler de la perte de
l'Algérie du regret du pays perdu
ah bon oui de tout son passé de toute la
nostalgie que ça évoque
dans son délire ah ouais il se drogue
alors il a rien compris un bon vous lui
souffler c'est un micro et puis lui
on s'en fout un peu c'est ça sert pas à
grand chose
j'aime pas les tricheurs
une ordure une couille molle
nous on s'en va avec la dame on va faire
l'amour et puis tu te démerdes
certainement pas je suis mariée
[Musique]